[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here welcome
back to another two by one video and to
another q a asking phd number 33. we do
this once a month and it is october it's
not over yet it's a very busy tech tober
but we're in it we asked you guys what
you wanted to know on twitter and you
had plenty of questions of course so
these are the best of those all right so
thoughts on apple screwing the oneplus
event okay this was kind of
funny depending on how you look at it
but also kind of unfortunate
it's a symptom of this busy techtober
season so oneplus made it very clear
that they're going to be announcing
their oneplus 6t in new york in an event
in the morning on october 30th
then apple
big company but i'm sure they've been
planning their event for a while too
they've also made an announcement for an
october event they're going to have an
event also in new york also in the
morning
also on october 30th so naturally
oneplus a smaller company kind of bent
to that and moved their event to the
29th it's not just that they don't want
to be overshadowed by apple i'm sure
that's like on their mind but also a lot
of people covering tech a lot of
journalists a lot of youtubers people
like me we're gonna go to both we're
gonna go to oneplus event and we're
gonna go to apple's event and if a lot
of people are going to both they have to
pick oneplus didn't want people to not
be able to go to their event that was a
big part of it so they moved their event
forward a day to the 29th so now it's
gonna be the 29th one plus the 30th
apple i don't think they did it on
purpose or anything i think they both
were planning their event uh a long time
ago but it's just kind of unfortunate
that there's just not enough days left
in october how was the jre the joe rogan
experience that was a fun podcast if you
guys haven't seen that i did go on the
joe rogan podcast uh we shot that
yesterday the video is live i'll drop a
link with a like button if you want to
watch it if you watch it back it's like
two and a half hours and we talked about
a lot of stuff a lot of tech included
some other topics included as well so uh
but it was fun joe knows actually
probably more about tech than people
give him credit for i'm not a case
person yeah you don't have any cases huh
no i don't do cases
yeah but you switch phones so often even
if you drop them that's what people say
pop a sim card out i still take good
care of my phones people are like oh you
get a new phone every two weeks you
might be right but i still take really
good care of my phone oh someone asked
how was your streamies experience that
was also pretty fun so uh for those who
don't know i recently attended the
streamy awards in la and beverly hills
and we actually won a streamy award for
the science or education category
that was incredible
marquis brownlee
[Applause]
now i didn't really push for this i
completely did not expect to win but
when the cameras and the lights hit and
they said that i won the category that
was pretty amazing um i think there
should be a tech category though like
i'm not trying to hate or anything and
i'm not an expert on award shows but on
youtube there's definitely a
distinguished tech community and also a
distinguished science and education
community and a lot of the other
channels in that category who i love by
the way were nominated for those those
science and tech and education reasons
and i think a separate science and tech
category specifically consumer tech
would deserve its own category too
nonetheless though i'm very grateful for
all of your support and i'm that's the
only reason that we won that award so
i'm really happy about that but overall
the experience was fun the show if you
watched it was very interesting uh and i
hope to be back uh john good old john
four lakers the og says he saw my pixel
3 screen issues and he says he's had a
bootloop issue with his
do i still recommend the device so i'll
actually show you what mine looks like
this is my pixel 3 xl right now and if
you'll notice
uh it has a stripe a pink stripe
straight down the middle a full
brightness stripe of dead pixels
completely in the center of the display
so that's pretty strange i feel like
i've had bad luck with phones this year
i looked it up if you look up a pink
stripe down the phone's display issue
it's something that's happened in the
past with other phones often samsung
phones or phones with samsung panels
this is a samsung panel and uh there's
no real
guaranteed fix for it it's just kind of
a thing that happens it sucks now i
can't use this phone anymore and i'll
have to get a new one and it's probably
gonna be replaced super soon but
that's that's terrible it's a quality
control issue it's not gonna happen to
everyone's in fact it's probably gonna
happen to almost no other phones
hopefully anyway but like i said i feel
like i've had bad luck i might have
remembered uh or you might remember a
couple days or weeks ago my razer phone
too straight out the box was completely
unresponsive i had to wipe it and start
over from the bootloader to get it to
actually work again to my screen touches
which again
that's super rare right like if this
starts happening to a lot of people's
phones then yeah i'll stop recommending
it and it does seem like pixel's had a
lot of weird things happen to it lately
that are unfortunate but uh i still feel
the same way about it oh this is a
really sad question do you think phone
companies that have done away with the
headphone jack will ever bring it back
no
i don't think it's gonna it's like a
floppy drive not that it's the same age
but like once people have just gotten on
board with getting rid of a port it
usually doesn't come back we often have
a lot of rumors and leaks about flagship
phones but we cannot say the same about
tablets or computers like the upcoming
ipad pro what are your expectations
about the apple event considering the
few details we have by now
it's a good question but i think that's
actually discounting how much has leaked
about these new ipads we actually kind
of also already know what to expect with
the new ipad the new specs the new a12
the new display the smaller bezels the
face id that works in portrait or
landscape all these things are coming to
ipad pro you can read articles about it
it hasn't leaked like people having a
physical ipad in their hands there's no
unboxings online of it before it's come
out
but we kind of know what to expect i'll
leave a really good article below that
links to like pretty much everything
we're going to see at this october event
why do you only talk about phones saying
quality tech videos as your tagline
uh it's just kind of all that's been
coming out over the past few weeks i
keep using this hashtag tectober to
refer to all the stuff that's coming out
in like september october november but
mostly this month uh which is just a
whole lot of new phones and things
coming out right before the holiday
season so you get your stocking stuffers
and you get your new stuff um but we've
done all kinds of other videos before
this holiday season push we started a
series all about cars not that long ago
called autofocus and a whole bunch of
stuff about cameras we've done a whole
bunch of stuff about other tech but yeah
this this particular time of year if you
look back at the last couple videos it's
a lot of fun okay here's a good one and
maybe you guys can play along you can
pick between two different things for
your device super power
30 days of battery life or
free one gigabit internet connection 24
7. choose only one
go ahead and write yours i already know
a minus
it's pretty easy i'm picking the free
super fast incredible internet because i
already have a solution to the first
battery problem which is just i charge
my phone every day but there is no
solution to
bad wi-fi
bad internet there's dead spots around
new jersey and new york there's
bad airplane wi-fi that i just dealt
with last night so to always have the
the phone superpower of always having
lightning fast internet videos never
buffer nothing ever lags or stutters as
far as streaming
that's uh that's where i'm gonna go all
right so what convinced you to go to the
two to one aspect ratio for your videos
and why not 60 frames per second so
that's two different questions on the 60
frames a second i'm i'm not a big fan
like i i've tried other frame rates for
videos i've tried 24 frames per second
to me 24 frames per second on the
screens that you're watching that are
all calibrated towards multiples of 30
things look choppy pans look choppy
smooth motion looks choppy 24fps looks
bad to me and then 60fps looks
too smooth now i can say there are some
advantages to being smooth as far as
showing animations and stuff but for
that i prefer slow-mo so i'm pretty much
30 fps for life but then why did i
switch to this two to one aspect ratio
honestly it's just a little bit more fun
hear me out like i'm fully aware that on
on tvs and laptops and most people's
phones and computers
uh you're you're 16x9 like you're used
to watching 16x9 videos with minimal or
no black bars that is true but then i
decided to give it a shot i can blame
some of the guys in the studio for
making me give it a shot but i gave it a
shot i can blame jon a little bit for
that too
um
but it turns out on this particular
camera i'm using it has some
mathematical advantages the monstro 8k
sensor that i shoot with in this red
camera when i shoot in 16x9 it crops in
a little bit when i shoot in two to one
i'm actually getting more width to this
gigantic sensor and it just
looks
better
it's just it just looks better to me and
a motif on the channel for a very long
time as far as me talking to the camera
and a lot of shots has been wide angle
shallow depth of field it's very
personal i'm right here next to the
camera uh but i can be even closer to
the camera when it's this wide
and uh it's just more fun to play with
framing with other stuff in the left and
right of me and when you do top downs
and you do all sorts of other stuff you
might have seen that last pixel 3 video
has a lot of really interesting shots
that look different from a 16x9 shot so
without diving into all the nerdy gritty
details of two to one basically we're
just having fun with it we're playing
with it i think i like it for now
hopefully you can deal with the little
extra black bars for the extra little
phone we get to have all right i'm gonna
end it at that a lot of good questions
for october but also a lot of videos
upcoming in these last couple days and
it'll bleed into november 2 and there's
a lot of stuff happening but thank you
for your questions thank you for
watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the very
next video
peace